this video is sponsored by logitech
yeah i understand how you feel but this
is what our ceo wants eric wang wants us
to focus on implementing blockchain
technology on our window blinds
look you work at blinder now this is
what we do
anyway this is getting off topic there's
something i want to show you let me
share my screen
nice background all right first of all
i'm your manager second of all shut up
it was either this
or that
all right so don't freak out but we have
a new competitor they're called shader
and they make window shades
see this that's their product
okay let's watch their ad real quick
power
intelligence
sophistication
[Music]
seduction
perfection
[Music]
the world's most luxurious window shades
powered by blockchain technology the
first decentralized window treatment
[Music]
by jacques lacroix
okay so who's going to tell eric because
i'm not
shawty's are you not jonah you're it
wait are you serious dude i swear i have
my finger on my nose right now well we
can't see it so too bad
actually why isn't your video on video
calls are way better than audio calls
how am i supposed to see your facial
expressions yeah turn on your camera bro
fine
happy
ew gross why is the quality so doo-doo
are you using a built-in camera
well yeah i mean it's on my laptop
do we not pay you enough get yourself a
webcam from logitech seriously it's
worth the high quality video oh check
mine out c922 pro hd
wait is that your webcam then how are
you i bought two so i can show it off
that's nothing
logitech 4k pro webcam very nice
joma just go to logitech's website and
get a webcam here look you can get any
one of these webcams and it'll make your
video look so much better come on
especially now that you're working from
home please for my sake for your team's
sake please all right if there's no
questions here's 10 minutes back oh and
joma don't forget to tell eric about
shader
good luck drama
thanks
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
every time we meet and we still don't
have blockchain technology on blinder i
lose a bit of my patience
what do you want joma
okay well about the blockchain stuff
i just don't really see how
how do i say this um
i don't see how blockchain is relevant
to window blinds
tokenomics
what
do you even know what tokenomics is
yeah yeah i do do you
of course
what is it
what is it
what is it not
okay um we have a competitor shader
they also make window blinds we can make
shades not blinds what we make blinds
not them do not put us in the same
category
i'm sorry
but i know
shader has been on my radar and that's
why we need to raise money fast well
that's what our series b will be for
right no no that's too slow and with the
current valuation i'll either lose
control of my company or will only get
pennies
look
i'm not an idiot i know blockchain has
nothing to do with window blinds but we
need to raise money and an ico will give
us that money so we can secure market
share against shader
do you trust me
gentlemen do you trust me
yeah yeah i do i do
go build me blind your coin
i mean
i don't know where to start start from
the beginning i have faith in you
i was gonna wait for the end of the year
but
i'm offering you a discretionary grant
of 10 million shares that's one percent
of the company this could be worth 10
million dollars if we become a unicorn
i've never made a coin and
on a whole new chain that's it's gonna
be hard
then you better start working
what jack lacroix
[Music]
thank you so much for taking this
meeting at such a short notice well you
are jack lacroix
it's lacroix like um
the drink right the sparkling water no
no the drinks like me not the other way
around but i'm not here for a french
lesson then what is this
you
i'm here for you
what do you want from me
do all americans treat meetings like an
interrogation
well i'm not a person that likes racing
time okay i have responsibilities then
why are you so behind in your career if
you're so important
look you're smart you're resourceful
you're curious but you're stunted by
your own perception of yourself being
the only coding bootcamp student has
made you feel small that you are not
good enough that you were punching above
your weight
and that verden has never left you
you know that's a lot of assumptions
you're making him with all due respect i
don't think you know i want you to come
work for me
and
i'm flattered but i'm pretty as a vp
happy happy that you offered wait
thank thank you um
it's generous offer but i all cash one
million a year
wait why why
i just don't
why me
because you're going to help me destroy
blender do your commitment build me what
you build for them then you can do
whatever you want with the money start
your own company i don't care but do
something worthwhile with your talent
look i've i've committed to blinder okay
it's not a perfect company i know that
but it gives me opportunities and they
recognize me for my work
ah recognition
maybe it's time to write your own story
instead of being a footnote in someone
else's biography
there are two types of people in this
world
lions and antelopes
the question is
which one are you
you have until tomorrow to this side
goodbye jamal
so that's basically it i either build
blinder coin
or i go against my boss
but i i don't even know if i can trust
this new guy
what do you think i should do
[Music]
so after four years you finally decide
to come to me for help huh
[Music]
thank you logitech for sponsoring this
video